good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Monday which
should be unbelievably disgusting but
it's not because Jack's returns to the
podcast today's Audio Only Jacks
Extravaganza is here hey turdy Lou hey
Jax how are you done I'm good thank you
for holding it down for me last week
it's a pleasure you will be also holding
some things down this week I know you
have your schedule ready to go and
you're really excited about it I can't
wait to post like back to the maternity
days you know oh yeah
um so I won't be on for the remainder of
this week but I wanted to podcast today
because I feel up to podcasting and I've
been going through some things some
personal things that I'm not quite ready
to share yet with everyone I will
eventually but um I did want to still do
an episode and also like a dress that my
absence but I'm just not ready to talk
about some stuff but I will I and you
guys is you know where to find me
um so I won't be podcasting all week
because I know turdy wants to do video
yeah in my video yeah she's desperate to
be in front of the camera the IT
department does not [__] around at toast
no it does not so Claudia's gonna be
guesting you know making the most
thirsting you know for the podcast which
we love and I love to be a toaster
um but I did have the bandwidth to
podcast today and I really wanted to and
there's so much going on so it needed to
be original recipe listen Jax you take
your time emotionally physically you
take your time and just know
turdy's got you thanks
[Music]
so we're just gonna do a regular episode
today like thank God Jax is back so much
is going on Taylor Joe Olivia Christian
the Dalai Lama yeah there's Dalai Lama
didn't make it into the Fast Five Oh
[__] because he wanted me to choose this
turn story about the movie you saw
yesterday yes I have a lot of thoughts
okay
um but we should talk about the Dalai
Lama because he's kind of canceled yeah
he issued an apology come to the club
which is like a crazy thing but then
like when you see what he's apologizing
for it's like oh
a little yikes yeah he was like asking a
kid to suck on his tongue I don't know
like I can't I don't know even the Dalai
Lama's not sacred I don't know all the
details so I'm not going to comment on
it but like you just see the video and
it seems like enough yeah yeah it's just
so your facial comment is no comment my
official comment is um I'm confused
and I don't like I don't know what's
going on yeah yeah no I understand plus
I'm not familiar like with the dolly
himself and his teachings and maybe like
tongue sucking is a big part of his
ethos
and yeah it's true to like judge other
cultures no for real it could be
something like that like you just yeah
for sure
um moving on actually my only real like
I I know it's gonna sound so dumb like I
don't really know what the Dalai Lama
does like I know he's like a Healer and
like a spiritual leader
um and I what I do know about him I know
from the Nexium documentary because he
actually visited Nexium it was like
Keith Ranieri the leader yeah it was
like his biggest goal to get the Dalai
Lama he worked all of his celebrity
connections and he got the Dalai Lama
the Dalai Lama came to Albany I think
and it was kind of like the craziest
part of the Nexium documentary like it
was bizarre there's always like a weird
celebrity yeah like the we were one
remember they had um Katy Perry
like oh she performed at their concert
yeah yeah also um the wework one they
had like a Gwyneth Paltrow and Ashton
Kutcher Cameo for some weird I think the
wife is gwyneth's cousin yeah yeah I've
been watching Gwyneth on Shark Tank a
little bit I watched well we watched
that one episode together yeah and I got
the diapers yeah what were they called
Kudos Kudos diapers they're good My
overall review was good don't take your
kids swimming in them because it
exploded like there was like like I
didn't even know what's like inside of a
diaper no it's like beads yeah yeah it
just got like two saturated but you
should use swim diapers anyway yeah if
you're swimming whatever
um overall and I would size up in them
that's all I would say but the material
is good there was another episode with
Gwen there was another episode with Gwen
yeah we're like on a nickname basis and
she invested in an interesting product
with the ashes no oh I saw something
about like a company that um
like helps deliver your ashes in a more
humane way because usually they just
arrive in like a clear trash bag
um that wasn't from our deer toasters no
I know I was thinking about deer
toasters no it's similar-ish it's a
company that freeze dries your breast
milk so usually breast milk in the
freezer lasts like from six months to a
year and it starts losing nutritional
value after three months but you can
send it to this company they'll freeze
dry it and then it becomes like this
powder and you can use it for up to
three years like putting it with water
in a bottle or even like sprinkling it
like nutritionally yeast over your
toddler's food and they get like the
benefits of breast milk for years to
come oh that's interesting it was
interesting it's very complex yeah I
don't think it's gonna be the next big
thing
who do you think is the most successful
guest shark in terms of Investments they
made on Shark Tank not like famous
before probably turdy Lou freebush yeah
I loved her episodes I wish she would
bring her back she was like really
polarizing though yeah no she had like a
really kind of smart business Acumen
yeah she did speaking of TV recap we
have a lot to recap today we have so
much tarika because you are caught up
and I've been watching Love is Blind oh
my God I know it's like taking the World
by storm some wanted to watch it because
it seemed like an actually good season
and it was good until a point my God
they drag everything out and we watch
the same people have the same
conversations just one time they're
doing wedding dress shopping and one
time they're doing a Boudoir photo shoot
no and also it's like ordinary people
are just not that interesting and I
don't want to hear you guys have a
conversation about ranking your favorite
fruits like that's not such a compelling
to me and
I know she's polarizing but like where's
Irina I know she disappeared well she's
irrelevant now to the show but there are
like there are people who aren't in
relationships who are invited to like
the cast parties and stuff because
they're still a part of like the plot
like that guy Josh and you know Irina
has beef with Micah she likes Paul and
then she has an ex she's actually like
really Tangled in the web yeah like
production should be inviting her around
yeah just to start stuff no I thought
the season was gonna be good like the
couples that emerged were good but then
we go into this weird holding period
where it's like I have no idea what
these people actually think and feel if
they really do plan on getting married
or now they're acting for us trying to
get to the wedding just to make a big
speech about how I'm choosing me yeah
well okay so that's the thing with love
is blind and why it was so great the
first time is that nobody knew it was
going to be on Netflix people really
just were like doing it for an
experiment not to get famous and like
the show didn't have this cult following
so it was just people who were like
actually really down to try something
new and they also they concentrated in
the Atlanta area and I just feel like
people from Atlanta are just like I
don't know like funny and like worldly
and it was just good this Seattle we're
definitely getting a lot of Seattle yeah
yeah no and um a lot of Seattle energy
this is so not like a a knock on Seattle
it's a beautiful very toasty City but
like there's definitely like a culture
there where everyone's like a little
weird and granola-y and you know like
the conversations that Paul and Zach
yeah I knew you were gonna say that
wouldn't happen in any other City no so
it's just like I only I feel like and
this is the longest season I couldn't
believe that I was watching episode 12
and weren't even at a wedding yet like
so it's just a lot of content
for like a group of people that I just
don't think are like that interesting
especially once they go home and they're
all working like it's always interesting
in the pods and then on vacation like
they're having sex for the first time
now at home like it's just it's just sad
I do agree and who
from the season were people saying that
you look like oh shut up I wish why did
you bring that up because I'm trying I
remember you showed me a video of her
yeah but was it Irena because she's
apologizing for being insensitive yeah
it was Irina and they think that you
look like Irina yeah they think I look
like Irina when actually the only thing
me and Irene have in common is we both
apologize for being insensitive no like
I don't I don't think you look like
Irina honestly like they're I'm not even
gonna say it there's someone else that I
thought that maybe people were saying
that you looked like Amber yeah yeah
well just because she's chubby and
brunette and that's like my whole thing
which is brunette no like seriously like
not really chubby anywhere you're gonna
have to like shed this I was just
talking to I think it was Remy about
that like I made a joke my whole sense
of humor my whole sense of self yep is
about like being fat and my whole sense
of humor I just I don't know what I'm
gonna do you guys are gonna have to deal
with it like for a little bit longer
until I can shed it no we will but can I
keep you in check
no no no okay because let me just finish
when you're coming for me accusing me of
only saying something because you're
chubby yes yes okay but I also defend
myself I feel like it's so important to
understand how like being chubby and
being fat is a state of mind of course
yes it's a physical being quite
literally it's definition but when
you've spent so much of your life being
overweight it's who you are on the
inside I I do understand that and that's
why I tend to gravitate more towards
people who are fat or who have struggled
with their weight because it's just it's
a personality trait yeah and I honestly
I don't trust people who have never
struggled with their weight now what do
you think about what do you do like it's
so you wake up in the morning then what
and like you just eat when you're hungry
and you stop when you're not and when
you're ordering from a menu it's just
like whatever you're in the mood for
yeah no I I really can't relate to that
sort of toxic mindset no me neither so
thus proving my point that weight is
it's just ironic because weight is
literally a physical thing but it's so
mental it's so emotional yeah no that
part I do understand like I feel like
I'm in that same boat where but I'm just
saying like if you're gonna accuse me of
like I'm not a phobia I'm gonna come
back swinging yeah no I mean you're
definitely
but not in this particular instance so
okay I'll let you have this one it's a
case but it's a situation
um so wait so back to love is blind and
we're gonna do a full TV recap at the
end with succession but I just want to
talk about love is why now because it
consumed my whole face it's gonna be the
TV recap of it yes this is the recap of
Love Is Mine okay so they'll be it's
like today's episode is a sandwich
and that's our title obviously okay
great I love when we just like check
things off our list someone write it
down so in terms of the couples that we
currently have let's like go through who
you think is going to make it who you
think is cute of course like there's
always one
it was you know uh who was it the first
oh uh Lauren speed Hamilton and Cameron
Hamilton it is obviously Brett and
Tiffany they're so well matched I think
she thought she was gonna have a really
hard time because she was one of the
older girls but being older on this show
sets you up for more success you know
thyself you're not immature like Irina
you've probably seen some things to the
point where whatever that person looks
like like you know that it's so
insignificant and you're not immature to
be like so fixated on looks yeah
he thankfully he's also extremely
handsome and she's very pretty and she's
very pretty and they're very suited for
one another and emotionally
psychologically I know and also on a
physical level like they are a match
yeah and I also liked um when I found
out that they hadn't had sex and all a
lot of the other couple stayed in Mexico
I was like oh my God we trouble in
Paradise but she was on her period like
I like that she shared that yeah it was
and then they contacted sex yeah you
know and I think they're def they're not
even a question for me no they're not
even a question for me he reminds me so
much of Zach like some when your husband
yeah not his personality but when he was
showing her his apartment oh my God
knickknacks and his sneakers and how he
has the paper towel holder and it's like
a magnet like I was literally having
flashbacks to seeing zag's apartment for
the first time Jackie I totally forgot
how I thought the same thing because
he's obviously like a guy who likes like
gadgets and gizmos of Plenty yeah who's
it's and what's its Galore he's just
like a techie guy with the VR thing you
know his alarm clock is like definitely
really weird like yeah that's so your
husband he like loves again and like
Zach we've been watching together he
thinks Brett is sick like yeah okay and
when I said like this is literally you
he's like that is a compliment no 100
and he's like financially stable I did
think like I what I really liked about
the first season of Love is Blind is
they went really deep on people's
financials because it's so important
Amber and Barnett yeah but we got like
actual figures they're being a little
bit more vague this time but I think
there is like a discrepancy between how
Tiffany lives and how Brett lives and I
wish they would just like dive in a
little deep because she just appears
like salty like bougie bread bougie brat
yeah but I feel like in terms of how
much money they make they're probably on
a similar playing field like it's just
about uh philosophy of how you spend
your money yeah but it's also like she
had a roommate and he didn't you know
like so there I feel like there actually
is like a an imbalance okay that's which
is fine I think it's never gonna I'd
like to hear about it more apples to
apples and he said like he'll pay 70 60
40. 80 20.
um next couple who and by the way if
they don't get married like I'm done
with this show because then I'm just
watching fraudulence I agree I agree the
next couple and I know you didn't finish
but we got to the wedding Chelsea and
Kwame I think so I didn't watch the last
three episodes please spoil them I don't
care when I realized last night that I
wasn't caught up and that I had three
more like I just wanted to cry like I've
been powering through and it's so bad
right now it it no it's a major lull
like it's just so repetitive so we got
to Chelsea and kwame's wedding Chelsea
said yes and now we're waiting for Kwame
they did like a cliffhanger I do not
think he's gonna say yes but there's one
thing that's bothering me about it
because to me Kwame is so here like for
the show like I just get that vibe from
him he doesn't want to move he's very
settled in his life and also this moving
question is not supposed to be an issue
on Love is Blind like you go to a
certain city yes and I understand that
Portland and Seattle are close to each
other but there's a reason why they go
to like a city
so that this isn't an issue so that they
avoid it yeah because it's hard to make
your like to uproot your life so
um the only thing that's like making me
question Kwame like maybe saying yes I
don't know if you've noticed Chelsea's
ring
no it's huge and all the other girls
like have pretty much the same ring it's
like a very generic dating show like
Neil Lane Vibe um and I read somewhere
that production of course pays for the
Rings but the guys can choose to pay for
like an upgrade themselves and her ring
appears to be so big
making me think like Kwame was like
certain
well when he proposed he was certain if
he only became uncertain like you know
over the last few weeks and when he saw
Micah look I guess and maybe it's
Moissanite maybe it's more tonight
that's true but it's still like you'd
have to pay for that like it just it's
it's interesting to me that is
interesting yeah just a little fun fact
that I that you have served I was just
like nitpicking because at the
bachelorette party showed her ring to
her friends because she was like wasted
and I was like oh my God none of the
other girl's Rings look like that yeah I
think that they are a really good match
but I just don't know if kwame's look
like wants to be married and when they
were talking about like having kids and
how overwhelming that was they were
talking about going to Cabo laying out
I'm like you shouldn't be worrying about
that like right now it looks like you're
looking for an excuse an issue even
though like these are just people who
are a little bit older so you do have to
actually think about that yeah but it's
like that should excite you if you are
older and that's what you want and
that's why you came on this [__] show
you know I'm telling you I think he came
on the show like for fun he gives me
that kind of Batiste energy like I
didn't watch that season well you didn't
miss anything but
um I don't I'm gonna
um if we're guessing I would be shocked
if they got married because like it
seems like they
like each other they're having fun but
it's a little too serious to like
actually get married between them I
think she's obsessed with him and he
like is so annoyed by her that's my vibe
yeah people were saying like I saw
people's stories like ruining it for me
saying like that Kwame is like not that
into Chelsea I haven't gotten there yet
like I feel like he's actually been
they've been having a good time but I
could see him getting annoyed by her I
could I also I do like how he stays home
with the dog all day I know it's like
kind of an ideal setup yeah
um okay next couple let's go to Micah
and Paul I like cannot get a read on
them and I know Michael was like very
close to becoming
um a major villain just because of like
her friendship with Irene and she like
was being like a little bit of a [__]
in the pods but yeah
um yeah she like subverted everyone like
her and Kwame like should have been
together and then her and Paul like just
made this pact and yeah and then she was
like acting like a heartlet like in
Mexico in Mexico when she was flirting
up a storm with Kwame she was they were
blackout like it was wrong it was wrong
but she saved herself like her break
from Irena and then her um actually like
I think her Paul are cute I think her
and Paul are cute but I can't get a read
on them and I do feel like it could be a
big no yeah and she's just going through
the motions I also don't know if like P
people who are so different can actually
be like a match he's so like even when
they were talking about his apartment
like he's so granola he's like a lot of
the girls I dated like garden and wear
overalls and like work run only and
she's like very like glamor when you saw
her friends looks like girls like we
would know you know yeah she's like very
kind of
be different for sure one Opposites
Attract yeah two she is his mother oh my
God she is his mother I thought that was
the craziest scene yeah and so maybe
like you know they say like boys like
marry their mom so maybe like
subconsciously that's what he's been
looking for yeah but I could see I could
see her saying no to him because like
she just is not that into him I could
also see him saying no to her because he
just doesn't seem into anything he's
just like mute yeah I'm monotone but I
thought that scene with the friends was
really crazy and and the friends were
the friend was wrong yeah their friends
being crazy the friend was blackout and
the friend also just like wanted to like
start stuff on TV like I didn't think I
didn't have put any substance or weight
into the what her thoughts were at the
time is it causing an issue between Mike
and Paul and I thought Michael handled
it poor poorly because the friend like
Paul didn't do anything other than just
be boring yeah what he was saying and
the friend calls him out for being
long-winded like that's [__] rude she
was so rude she was so rude Micah should
have defended her man and that was like
a bad look for everyone except for Paul
yeah but now like Paul's doing somewhere
Paul stewing in the corner with his beer
I don't think they'll get married me
neither I just don't see it as like a
true like love match yeah I agree um
then we have Zach especially when
they're both like you know thinking
about the person they left behind except
then when Paul saw Amber he had the
perfect reaction which was putting it to
bed yeah but
no I know it's just like
I what nothing say it like I think it's
easy to put that former connection to
bed when like physically you're more
attracted to the person that you chose
oh yeah like at that point like The
Superficial elements take over yeah
because you're out of the pods like
you're out of that emotionally you
already
then you're in a pickle like I feel like
that's where Micah is with Kwame and
Paul yeah yeah because they're really
equally cute right but Paul doesn't feel
that way and also it's so crazy how it's
so much about type because I would say
all these people for the most part are
an equal levels they're attractiveness
uh yes with the exception I think of
Paul who's probably the hottest that's
so crazy that you think that because I
don't really think that and also like of
the girls I will I think the girls are
all really attractive but it's just
about type like I think Jackie is so
stunning me too but I think anyone who
who matched with her like would have
been so she's jailed she's literally
she's not well okay we'll talk about her
because I also didn't see her um her
crumbling okay well let's talk about her
and Marshall then wait wait but I was
just saying something about the
attractiveness the plot twist of the
entire show was
the reveal between Zach and Irina yeah
and not to be rude but I really was just
like thinking when Zack saw Irina like
that he might not be obsessed and the
fact that it was the complete opposite
no like um that he wasn't cute enough
for her and then I started looking at
him different because she was like
saying all this mean stuff about him
that he's a cartoon when he was in the
pods like I thought he was totally fine
okay so
I would say like physically just like
physical attributes he's definitely a
good looking guy but it's his manner
it's his mannerisms it's the way he
talks the way he stares and like
honestly a lot of the stuff that Irina
was saying which was so rude wasn't
wrong like he does have like serial
killer Vibes and when she said cartoon I
know everyone is like cartoon Christian
I actually think she misspoke because
she then she kept repeating herself and
she kept saying fictional character
being like Oh you remind me of someone
from a movie and yeah he is a Property
Brother like that's what she was
thinking at the time so I don't think
that that was her intention but it
definitely came out poorly but yes I
know what you're saying like on a
physical level like out of the two of
them I think a lot of people would
consider Zach quote better looking and
then she was the one who had a problem
with it so we must have been really
[__] weird and realized so it's just
it's crazy how it's just so much about
taste and not even what the person looks
like and it is about mannerisms and I'm
also starting to doubt the process
because I was like thinking about if I
were in the pods and like some of the
things you have to talk about and it's
like I wouldn't open up to a wall like
no that I can't see the person on the
other side like what if they're just
like
set and even when in some of the
conversations like some of the people
who were talking like one person's
opening up and the other person's like
fidgeting with something if you were
[__] fidgeting with something while
I'm opening up about something like I I
wouldn't have feel warmly towards you
like yes but
I think also you would never open up to
a wall but I think maybe actually a lot
of people would it's like much less
scary no I know but I feel like then
you're not falling in love with the
person on the other side of the wall
you're kind of just falling in love with
the way that they React to what you're
saying yeah that's true it's you know I
feel like it's without seeing someone's
manner or something it's not just about
like we have an emotional connection and
will that take us through like it's like
we liked what the other person said but
then there's a million other things that
come into play like demeanor mannerisms
faces that you make you know body
language yeah yeah
um okay wait so let's go keep going with
a couple so now that we're on Zach and
Irina Zach and Bliss which honestly like
Jackie when they were in Mexico and
Jackie was like Wow Bliss Dodge double
look good for her
I I actually don't think I've ever had
less respect for anyone than Bliss like
not only did she take back a guy who
chose someone elsewhere and really chose
someone who was like and she was not
wrong when she said like I would
definitely think different of you like
you chose I mean like I know Irina just
like you do and she's not like a great
person so she knows that about him she
was second fiddle she took him back went
on a date with him and she had
absolutely no obligation to like pretend
to like him like you know a lot of
people do and then she accepts his
proposal on the boat when they clearly
have no chemistry it was so [__]
weird I didn't see it that way oh I did
it looked like loserville oh I feel like
for whatever reason like she really
likes him and when they saw each other
like it was a a mutual attraction
and like I think Bliss just really wants
to be like a wife and a mom into and
Zach wants those things too and when two
people want something so badly like you
can make it work from there like so do
you think they'll get married
I don't know I I'm literally like where
I am they're one episode in the like you
know what I mean okay so they get
engaged they meet her parent his family
oh no his he doesn't like have family
yeah her family
um her mom is fine and then her dad
comes with his stepmom and he's like so
against it it's like really awkward and
contentious okay I really like these
parents we need to put more respect on
their names because the idea just kept
being like to Zach like if Harry came
home and said I'm engaged to his
girlfriend television after two weeks
like I would call the police of course
and best case scenario is you're wrong
yeah but most likely you're not yeah and
so I
but also it's like you're on a TV show
you don't want to come off as like you
know the big bad parents so you kind of
just have to like let your but I
actually really liked Micah's parents
reaction they were like obviously not
here for this but they're like we know
our daughter yeah and I feel like if you
if trust trust your child then just let
them see this through because here's the
thing at worst they're not gonna get
together like they're gonna have their
heart broken right right at best they're
gonna get married and like a lot of
these people are older and really want
to be married and it's like okay it's
not conventional but it's something and
it's not like it's not like there have
been no people who have actually been
successfully married there have actually
been like three or four couples who are
totally married yeah and like really
married Amber Barnett Lauren and Cameron
who else so I guess it would just be
like I feel like I could maybe get over
the the process of yeah you know the
experiment it would just depend on the
person that might like a child or at
home yeah yeah but it's also hard to you
know judge that immediately and then if
you do judge the person based on like
what they're giving you then um you're
kind of like [__] judgmental 100
um and then the final couple is my what
I'm saying is the parents are in an
impossible position yeah of course of
course but you also just like for TV
like wanna
just come off normal and like yeah this
is great and then text your kid like
what the [__] are you doing you know but
then the kid goes to the camera my
parents are by the way what nerve like
kwame's Mom is not coming yeah and I
understand that of course and she's also
really mad because she wanted him to
marry someone of similar background and
like Chelsea's you know not and that's a
tough conversation I'm sure she doesn't
want to [__] explain why she wants
her son to marry someone from the same
background like that's [__] that's fair
honestly yeah that is fair
um and then Jackie and Mark and Marshall
so what ends up happening is that Jackie
and Marshall break up she goes on a date
with Josh actually before she breaks up
with Marshall that's what that's what
the camera showed happen she then said
she went on a date with him after okay
yeah I don't care when she sit down with
Marshall she's like I just saw Josh so
whatever
um but everyone's like quaking over they
have this kind of contentious
conversation he's been like a really
nice guy the whole time she's clearly
she has some sort of undiagnosed
disorder she's a very like her mood
swings are insane and sometimes it's
funny like when she was in the pool just
like talking about all the other couples
I was like oh that's funny because she
went from like being mean to laughing
but she she has something she's really
she's unbalanced
um and he's been so calm with her and
he's really been like a pee jam and he
was just done at this point so
he um he was like we're done and he
wanted the ring back she was like no you
gave this to me like no and everyone's
like Jack he's so evil give him the ring
back after all you put him through but
it's like it's literally you know in his
ring it's just as much hers as it is his
production pays for the ring yeah and
she had just like one of the regular
like and then in her statement because a
lot of people have been coming over
she's like I know you guys like thought
it was rude I should have given it back
to Netflix not
Marshall right he was just like trying
to make a point to like be dramatic but
it's literally not your ring yeah it's
neither of theirs
I know she's like the villains that's
what I've seen and I haven't seen her
I've seen the mood swings and but
everyone I kind of could understand a
little bit like I feel like she's
struggling because she's like really
happy with Marshall and she wants to get
like carried away with the whole process
but she has her family who are not here
for her going on the show and getting
married and engaging like that's a real
buzz kill you know when like you feel
like you're doing something that goes
against like what your family wants for
me for you and like it's conflicting so
I understand a little bit why she's like
having these extreme moods but and then
you know she met his family and I
thought she was they were all really
sweet and like she came out of it really
quickly even though she was having a
breakdown before she was having a
breakdown she's just very emotional she
is but I also feel like and I started
feeling this way in the pods first like
Marshall's a little controlling and I
feel like he was one controlling when
anyone else was talking to Jackie like
that's the [__] show like that's
insane like you're not engaged yet like
that's what this is for and like he was
upset that Josh didn't like mention his
connection but like honestly I'd
probably move like that too if I would
be silent look at what happened with all
the girls everyone knows everyone's
business and like I literally think
Micah got engaged to Paul just to stick
it to each other 100 who Amber yeah so I
understand all that I thought that
Marshall's reaction was like really
controlling and possessive of Jackie
when it's like she's still single she's
in the game and then when he said that
he looked at her like a project that was
me no it was me but I do think it was
revealing and also true which is like
he wants to be the one to fix her and
like her to Blossom under his tutelage
and it's just like she's her own person
like you don't marry something more like
get this serious with someone who
because of potential it's like yeah do
you love her as she is with all of this
or like or not so I don't know I feel
like they're really not a good fit for
each other and also what she wants is
like what the Marshall said like a toxic
kind of love you where it's like more
passionate and fiery and aggressive Josh
a drama in the bedroom and whatnot and
so for that reason one for that reason
that's probably why she's still single
yeah and two for that reason she's not
gonna be able to see Marshall for the
what he brings right his good traits
yeah no he's like very stable looking to
settle not he's like emo boy yeah yeah
and I think she finds him to be soft you
know he's like a little beta
yeah no he's like yeah he's just like in
his feelings and and she's not into that
look no not at all but I would think
that in the pods you'd get a sense of
that yeah no and also you just have to
be self-aware like you're on TV yeah
um so the weddings are coming up we
obviously don't know anything yet which
is just beyond annoying after how many
hours I've spent of this show and that's
your recap
That's all folks it's not it's not all
folks because we still have a whole ass
show today I am I can't believe we just
did that at the beginning honestly I
didn't think it was gonna be you should
really cut it and just put it at the end
I really didn't think it was gonna be so
long I'm sorry I thought it was gonna be
like a really cute quick moment for us
no no when they take up this much of
your time in your brains because having
to hear people say like that many times
I'm gonna have some feelings about it
and it's really making me look at myself
and count how many times I say like by
the way it's unbearable the same it's
unbearable but you also have to remember
these are Ordinary People yeah and
they're not media trained like we're
just watching people be people and and
sometimes that can be really [__]
boring but refreshing yeah unless you
have a character like a Jackie or Irina
but then you're like wow you're so crazy
we need people like making the show yeah
I can't watch Micah and Paul all day no
um so let's dive into the stories I I do
feel like it's time okay turdy Lou yeah
without further Ado here are the fast
side stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
honey so it is the easiest way to save
money when you're shopping on your
iPhone or computer thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best
ones it finds to your cart here's how it
works imagine you're shopping on one of
your favorite websites when you check
out the honey button appears and all you
have to do is Click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for that website and
if they find a working coupon you will
watch the prices drop I have saved money
on so many things for myself gifts for
other people I've sued money on clothing
obviously which is what I spend most of
my money on but food makeup Electronics
so many of my favorite websites work
with honey and it's so fabulous it's so
easy and when you use our link it's free
to download and honey just doesn't work
on desktops anymore they also work on
iPhones so you can activate it on your
Safari on your iPhone now and you can
save money when you're shopping on the
go which is
fabulous if you don't already have honey
you are straight up missing out by
getting it you're doing yourself a solid
and when you use our link you are
supporting our show get PayPal honey for
free at joinhoney.com toast that's
joinhoney.com toast thank you honey for
sponsoring today's episode today's
episode is also brought to you by a new
sponsor primally pure if you want to
have your healthiest year yet and become
the most vibrant version of yourself
start here cleaning up your skincare
products swapping for natural options is
a must if you want to feel good and glow
from the inside out and primarily pure
has harnessed the power of natural
ingredients in their complete line of
non-toxic beauty products so they have
skin body baby hair and Home Products
and they're called following favorite
natural deodorant primarily pure
products are handcrafted with real raw
ingredients to optimize your results and
your overall health I recently got a ton
of stuff from primally Pure at baby and
for me too and it's been great I
switched to a natural deodorant for now
which uh you know natural deodorant gets
a bad wrap it does it does and I have
tried to say to a natural deodorant
before and and I've switched back yeah
right but I am sticking with the
lavender primally pure deodorant
honestly it doesn't have that natural
deodorant smell
feel Vibe Vibe that's fair and so many
of the other products I have their room
spray it smells so good it's like
non-toxic I don't like a lot of like
fragrances going around my house I have
their hand soap like they have a whole
line of products and all of them are
amazing depending on what you need like
literally everything I've used has been
wonderful if you're on the fence about
making the swap to non-toxic products
especially natural deodorant check out
their five star reviews at
primallypure.com
once you're convinced use code toast for
15 off your primally pure purchase so
that's
www.primally
p-u-r-e.com slash toast and use code
toast to check out for 15 off your order
that's primallypure.com toast for 15 off
your order
thank you turdy Lou always with the
great codes and Link saddle save that's
quite literally what I do for a living
okay are you ready for our first story
well I wasn't ready when I first heard
it but yes I am ready Taylor Swift and
Joe Alwyn have broken up after six years
of dating Entertainment Tonight
exclusively learned and broke the news
that Taylor and Joe broke up a few weeks
ago they also learned that the split was
amicable and it was not dramatic
Entertainment Tonight told the
relationship had just run its course
it's why Joe hasn't been spotted at any
shows she is currently on the era's tour
which heads to Tampa next week
I mean it's been a really long time
since like a piece of Pop Culture news
is like really shocked me and with this
not only have they been together for so
long so you just kind of forget about
people like they're just settled they're
out to sea their ship is out to sea and
we get no real updates on them because
they're so private except her songs
which are so glowingly which are not
even like
they're like some of the most beautiful
love songs yeah it's just like the story
is over yeah I've solved love yes it's
done the case closed I'm only gonna
write about the love right that's why it
was so shocking right and
I will admit now now I feel like I can
you know when they first started dating
he's not my type
um I don't really know him he's not that
famous like I wasn't obsessed like I
think a lot of people are obsessed with
the relationship I'm not I've actually
never seen him in anything I think
people are obsessed with the love for
Taylor yes and that stability for Taylor
that I loved and I think and the Loyalty
I think he was really there for her
during like dark times you know Kim and
Kanye reputation so I do really feel
like every relationship serves its
purpose in one way or another in your
life and I feel like he served his
purpose and as much as like I'm sad that
Taylor like has been going through a
breakup and probably writing some great
songs I am not like not excited about
like she's single now and we forget
because it's been so long but she was
like the single gal to a point where
like it became her thing I'm ready like
who did she date next like I'm excited I
don't think it's gonna be like that
anymore for so many reasons one like I
think for a lot of guys like they don't
want to be lumped in they don't want to
be a part of that group like look at
Jake Gyllenhaal like the fans or her you
know what I mean like so to even go on a
date with someone have a song written
about you it's just like is it worth it
if you you really have to think you're
gonna find love with this person and I
think for Taylor like she I think she
loved the privacy of the last six years
and dating someone more low-key and I
don't think she wants a relationship
that everyone's talking about everyone's
talking about her man like
I think she'll continue to be low-key
about it I don't think it's going to be
like you know Taylor and Tom Brady and
she's on like a press tour of dating
well dumois posted and we have to of
course take with a grain of salt that
Taylor and Joe been broken up for a
while and she's actually seeing someone
new an older more low-key guy yeah that
tracks yeah it does track I don't know
if it's true or not but I I believe
they've been broken up for a decent
amount of time and you know Taylor and
she'll admit this and I think people
used to use it as like a slight against
her but she meticulously plans out
everything in her life and I think you
know the timing she has a weekend off
this is like the longest break in the
tour I think it's like a week and a half
so it gives everyone time to kind of
like move on forget about it
um but now of course everyone's going
back and looking at things she's been
doing changes she's been making things
she's been saying in the last couple of
weeks that might have indicated that
something is she saying the one which is
a breakup song but every song of hers is
a breakup song no so not only that it's
like she replaced
a core song in the set list which was
invisible string and everybody knows is
about Joe Greene was the gun one of the
last three albums that Joe no no not
every not every song No London London
boys obviously about you oh yeah like
all the lover ones really that's like
the Joe era like not really
yes really okay but so what I'm saying
not every song is about but the
Invisible String one is like in my
opinion like the greatest not only most
obvious but like it's like a song
dedicated to Joe and she removed it and
replaced it to the one which if you
don't know what about the one about him
being poor she's she calls important
invisible string and what but what about
the other one which one king of my heart
oh all the boys in their fancy cars with
their Range Rovers in the Jaguars never
took me quite the way you do or maybe
Paris your roommate's cheap uh cheapest
screw top Rose that's how there's so
many instances where she calls it before
maybe he had enough did she still sing
king of my heart
I don't know if king of my heart is not
on the set list
king of my heart is the best song I just
really hope that like this doesn't then
I don't think it will because like I am
I think this weekend Tampa is gonna get
like a breakup show I am hoping dreaming
dying for one of these shows of course
I'm hoping that it's mine for her to
sing peace like I don't know how you
write peace about someone and maybe
maybe it wasn't enough that he could she
could never give him peace like but yeah
it's not a love song like it's like an
anxiety song yeah I don't think it falls
into the category of things we can't
sing anymore because I'm processing this
breakup I agree I agree but I I hope
that category is not gonna be a thing I
don't think it will be because I think
she's already processed everything she
probably you know when you're breaking
up with someone especially a long-term
relationship like things deteriorate for
a while before you make the choice and
like I think you do a lot of The
Grieving before like I feel like by the
time she even embarked on this tour like
she's known what's up yeah yeah yeah
it's just it's it was so shocking and
and I really can't stress enough how I'm
like I'm not mourning him at all like I
really wasn't ever like die hard
obsessed
I if I'm being completely honest thought
she could do better
um but I was happy for her you know and
they bless you she sees on it it's true
she seemed really balanced and happy
you're like mourning the stability yeah
because I think that's like what she
craves because so much about her life is
like so crazy so for that I'm sad but I
do feel like I'm ready for her to move
on yeah but I also feel like when they
started dating
where she was versus where she is now
it's like she's almost a different
person and like in her growth in her
career and her success like she's never
been this popular yeah ever yeah and
I don't but I think she's also the type
to be like well he was with me when I
was down like I'll always you know I
don't I understand by him I have to
imagine that like when your life in your
career is like predicated on so many ups
and downs like you don't make decisions
in haste like when you're going through
a bad time and when you're at the time
oh I'm at the top of my game I don't
need him now like I don't think and I
also feel like because I've just been
watching a lot of I've just watched
George and Tammy and a lot of movies
about famous people biopics Johnny Cash
Walk the Line
um I feel like when you're at the top
that's when it's the loneliest yes and
when you're climbing out of something
you have a purpose and a Guiding Light
and like you are driven yeah but then
you reach the top in it and it only just
like it echoes the loneliness just
Echoes so I actually feel like even
though it might seem like oh she's on
top she just wants to like do her thing
and party and have fun it's like
I think that's when you want like
someone in your bedroom too and and to
actually like enjoy everything that
you've built yes having said that I do
also really feel like when we watch
those biopics it's always yeah you're at
the top but there's no one there with
you yeah
um I feel like Taylor's whole life has
been preparing her for that like I feel
like she's her always around her family
she's always around like her home
friends like she went through that era
where she only had famous friends and
now she's like two or three famous
friends but they're like actual friends
I feel like she set herself up
to you know whenever she reaches a peak
and maybe she's in it now maybe she's
still on her way up that she's not alone
yeah and then she is like fulfilled I
could also see how like she's constantly
surrounded by people she has her friend
like you know her artist friends these
people and there's always a lot of noise
and if she ever is truly by herself
it must be very quiet I just feel like
you're just like going to for chat with
me like like I feel like she's I feel
like she's I'm not going too fast I'm
not going to first half with you I'm
going tiffer tap with the concept of
like stardom and loneliness no and by
the way do you know what I mean 100 and
I think a lot of those are 100 true all
of the time but I just feel like Taylor
it's different I do I really do like
Taylor's not a party girl she doesn't
like do drugs like yeah she's always
with her family like her family is and
and I think for a lot of stars when they
become like untethered from their
families or their family betrays them or
something about money like that's when
they really like lose grip of reality
and that's when they become so
untethered and they just like you know
hang with people who give them drugs and
bad influences and the fact that Taylor
has remained so close to her family is
like very grounding for somebody in her
situation so I'm choosing to believe
that that's what's happening yeah no I
understand it's just great like we
literally watch so many yeah we watch um
Patsy Cline's biopic we watch old school
country Loretta Lynn Johnny Cash and
then I watch George and Tammy and um
it's crazy how it's just like everyone
who's at the top is just so unhappy and
they turn to all of this different
substances and it's like such a like
it's crazy how really so few people
escape that like
yeah
I don't I don't know yeah I feel like
but maybe it's also about being an
artist like you can't really be like a
creative
person without being a little tortured
yeah yeah and like searching for
something yeah yeah because you know
some people just become an accountant
right it's very cut and dry they're fine
and they're fine yeah but you know if
you want to like dig deep into the soul
like into your soul like it's just
it's a different piece yeah I just do
think a lot of those like cliches don't
apply here honestly I agree I do agree
are you ready for our next story yes
ma'am some happy relationship news when
one shape sinks it can be repurposed
build back together and set reclaimed
wood very Joanna gains set a float with
Olivia Colburn Christian McCaffrey who
are engaged she posted the announcement
on Instagram Friday in a picture a
carousel of him proposing to her I think
they were at Amman Gary in Utah they had
taken a road trip an RV RV she was like
so excited obviously follow her so I was
just watching the road trip and I was
shocked at him she was saying this is
like her dream vacation is to go like it
was not even like a big RV like it
wasn't like a coach bus it was like an
RV with like one room and a couch and I
was like damn and it was just her and
Christian Christian was driving and
Oliver sprinkles their dog was there
which does make everything more fun and
I guess they draw from LA to Utah and
they say that I'm in Gary and they got
engaged and it's so [__] beautiful I
think a lot of people like what were
watching the trip on her Instagram
Stories being like they're gonna get
engaged but people think that about
everyone who goes on a trip who has a
boyfriend like people do think that
about everything but I just want to say
I'm not one of those people and you did
say and I did say like I feel like this
would because it's the off season it's
just the two of them if you can live on
an RV with someone for a number of days
made for life and they're driving the
bus and like their driving skills like
and the you know shower situation and
the cooking and the makeup like you can
marry them I believe so I think the RV
was a test they arrived at the most one
of the most beautiful resorts in the
country right and he said that's my wife
that's my wife and then he had no doubts
yeah and she looked so happy she looked
so beautiful there were like a lot of um
because she put she got back from the
trip she got engaged and then like there
was like two or three days where she
didn't say anything yeah she got engaged
on the second and the News came out on
the fifth so between the second and the
fifth some of her friends were spoiled
it yeah like I think her sister posted a
story where there was like big balloons
in the background with like one of those
engagement ring balloons yeah
um whatever like it's all good no it's
all good and it's all like good news
right yeah spoiling good news is not
spoiling yeah and it's so it was fun for
the fans yeah I'm happy for her like I
think he's so cute and I just love that
I love this for her especially as like a
Niners girl myself yeah it's like a big
Bay Area queen I'm thrilled it also it
it hits harder like having just watched
the Culpo show and like just knowing
what she's about and what she wants out
of life and it's like this is what she
wants like she wants to be married and
settle down and have kids yeah and that
she's on the path to all of that I'm so
happy for her it also hits harder just
like knowing that she's now joining like
an elite Wags crew over in San Francisco
we know we have Kyle use check and his
wife you know iconic toasters we by the
way I was just saying this to Ben
because when we went to San Francisco
with Kyle and Kristen for the 49ers game
um
I met Claire Kittle who is George
Kittle's wife and she's so cute and so
nice and I hadn't I'm not like a big
footballer I hadn't heard of George
Kittle before that game when I tell you
not a day goes by that I don't see
George Kittle now it's like you know
when you you don't know someone or
something and then it's everywhere you
go George and I said I'm like Ben George
kills everyone Ben's like yeah he's also
like having a moment he's like coming up
right now like he's on all these
podcasts and he has like a bunch of
friends with like big shows YouTube
shows so he's popping up everywhere but
like I swear to God I'd never heard this
man's name in my life and now not a day
goes by that I'm not thinking about
George cuddle yeah
how life works you know it is and I do
agree with you though right you see him
everywhere he's everywhere but I also
now follow Claire so I see him
everywhere I see him every day I follow
her too that's that's also it but also
Ben said he's like having a moment
because like he was like had a really
good season and like you know there's
like a lot of you know when it rains it
pours yeah as Liz Lemon once said yes so
this is great for the Niners gang I know
so it's out just like another Elite
marriage oh and think about the wedding
like all the flags are gonna be there
and she's so I don't know who wouldn't
want to dress Her Like She's So stunning
she's not like a custom Versace dress or
something but I think she's also like
quite traditional and so yeah by the way
she is like I think her family is like
kind of religious like they're they're
gonna be and her and Christian are
religious she said on the show that like
when they get into fights and like
they're can't see their way out of stuff
like they pray together oh my God that's
so cute so cute speaking of prayer total
tangent but I did want to talk about
this because I saw an interview this
morning and I've been seeing a few that
Blac Chyna has been on this um kind of
like press journey and actually she
prefers she's going by Angela White now
I don't know if you know that she had is
having like a a come to quite literally
a come to Jesus moment she got all of
her filler dissolved she quit only fans
she is um she was baptized she's having
her she said this quote demonic tattoos
removed she's like a woman of Christ now
she looks so beautiful I saw this
interview she did and honestly like the
interviewer was like gushing over her
and he was just like how did you come to
this place she's like I just you don't
see it when you're in it I was like
happy doing all the things that I was
doing and then one day I like found
Christ and I was like I can't believe
I'm living my life this way and I'm
putting all these toxic things in my
body and this is how I'm making a living
and honestly she was so
she sounded so lucid and I I've never
ever in my life been a fan of Blac Chyna
like clearly I'm a Kardashian's fan for
China right we literally invented a word
after her I was so happy for her she
looked so healthy and happy and you know
salvation is real salvation is real I
was just watching George and Tammy and
eventually I don't want to spoil it um
but by the end of the show George finds
Christ and it's just it can be really
good for people it's it's amazing it's
amazing for people who are struggling
with a myriad of things like first his
friend who was like really an enabler
the whole show then one day just like
him and his wife found Jesus and like
they weren't about that life anymore and
that he kept trying to get George to see
the light and finally George doesn't it
just changes everything for him yeah and
I'm not I'm not obviously not a Jesus
girly
um and I'm not speaking like Jesus
specifically he's in the higher power
like a spirituality whatever religion it
is it can be so grounding I think
especially when you run in like you know
Hollywood which can be like you know
and when people treat you like a god
yeah yeah and then it's hard to have
perspective yeah I just thought it was a
really powerful interview if you can
catch she's been doing a bunch like it
was really interesting she went on cast
it was it was good stuff I'm really
happy for her yeah we said Christ and
the Kardashians are like weirdly
um religious religious so maybe this
could be like not weirdly sorry
surprisingly underratedly yeah
um maybe this could be common ground for
them they can you know take the kids to
church yes I agree yeah I think it's
good I think it's all good I'm happy for
Olivia and Christian me too obsessed
Beyond yeah
okay are you ready for our next story
yes an update in the in-law Saga I know
that's all taken over I'm obsessed the
beckhams are celebrating Brooklyn and
nichola's first wedding anniversary
together so Brooklyn and Nicola happy
anniversary they are together with
Victoria and David took a photo posted
it with a cake with a cake that had like
photos on it I bet Brooklyn cooked it
himself and you know they're putting up
a united front Victoria posted the photo
Nicola posted the photo like happy to be
celebrating their anniversary yeah and
I'm just at a place now where nothing
they do or say or post will convince me
otherwise like this even Victoria yeah
this is giving and I'm just so convinced
in my head and I don't have any proof
but I think they're so motivated to
prove people wrong even though I think
people are right that they're just like
posting like I really I like I'm not
buying it but maybe it's just because I
don't want to buy it but it's also like
you could celebrate you could be with
your in-laws and have a bad relationship
and take a picture and post it and like
yeah we're celebrating the anniversary
shirt it doesn't mean these people like
each other yeah I also felt like her
outfit was just like not what you wear
to hang with your in-laws yeah she was
like definitely like downplaying the
whole anniversary because she hates
America no no no no no no not Victoria
oh Nicholas what was she wearing she was
she's wearing like a crop top and short
shorts like that's just that's not
appropriate that's not what you wear
with your in-laws and especially
everyone else is wearing like pants it's
clearly like the air conditioning's on
in the home it's just like it's just a
sad it's just not like in-law outfit
there are outfits for certain things
just like when Celine was going to
dinner with Drew tiger that wasn't a
date outfit right this is not an outfit
that you wear with your in-laws yeah I'm
just at a place in my life where I don't
know what it would take for me to
someone to convince me that these four
get along I just know there's problems
and no photo is gonna convince me
otherwise I'll have to see it in person
no but I think that there can be
problems and there can be a photo oh
yeah of course of course but I think
this photo was posted to placate us and
try and convince us that there's nothing
going on when I know that there is yeah
and I will not be fooled Jackie no I
don't think that you would be I will not
be
but happy anniversary be that I will not
first you're married
marriage the hardest have you
experienced that no
um the fact that this was a year ago
we've been talking about them for a year
is so crazy like not to make everything
about me but what a year like so time
flies I know but it does feel like a
year ago when they came on our radar
because we had we never talked about
them before yeah their weddings it does
feel just really quick yeah I remember
when we talked about their wedding yeah
and we were just like did you still live
in New York yeah oh okay a year ago
April yeah uh we were just like what do
these two have to worry about there's
all the money in the world to pay for
the wedding no money mo problems and it
was then it started to all unravel it
did very quickly it was actually very
fast
um do I think the first year of marriage
is the hardest I don't remember it being
hard honestly yeah
so no so no that would be a no great
this is just my opinion that's not also
I do think covid
um throws think my first year marriage
was like the year before covid so then
like I would say like the next covet
year was hard it was our first year yeah
yeah yeah you know like being up each
other's asses working from home yeah
maybe that's why I don't feel like the
first year of marriage is the hardest
rule applies to me is because I think a
lot of people struggle with having
someone up your ass but like I crave to
be up someone's ass and I crave someone
up my ass like I hate being alone I love
that it's so not true no I know you hate
when people are up your ass you're
literally the first one to just dip out
of a gathering that's different even if
it's four people Gathering a four that's
different you're never like the one
who's like like you're always just all
of a sudden see my family when it comes
to my family like I like to be no when
it comes to your family you do it to us
no I don't yes you do we're one minute
we're laughing next I'm going really
yeah
there's no wind down there's no nothing
maybe I'm like trying to leave to go
back to bed maybe I'm just obsessed with
Ben with Ben yeah because I just said
like I didn't I like my bed but I feel
like sometimes when you're dipping out
like he's sculpting
maybe it's Theo usually Theo's with you
I don't know maybe I just hate you maybe
maybe it's me yeah it's me
I don't know what it is but no I didn't
find the first year of marriage I heard
us when you were 13 you didn't find that
your child bride I found it to be quite
relaxing
um and I also didn't find covid
to be that taxing but that's because we
spend so much time at home like it
wasn't that different than regular life
no it was different it was it was but I
don't remember or also maybe maybe I
experienced trauma and I forgot about it
that's so possible that's so turdy
that's so turdy for me to like go
through something like unenjoyable and
then not remember it but I actually
remember like when we were going through
code like we would remark on who's
handling it the best like we would Mark
amongst ourselves and we would say like
you and you are doing fine you Claudia
like your mental health was fine yeah
and you and Ben were fine yeah oh okay
so maybe I'm not misremembering as much
no no we like we definitely did a
ranking of like who was going who was
having the hardest time yeah because
that's like a fun thing to do no it is
and also what else were we going to talk
about and now if we I don't remember the
rest of the Ring he'd be like I just
remember everyone agreeing that like you
were fine oh my God someone we needed to
worry about it's so sad that I have this
amazing life and like this amazing
family and I'm constantly experiencing
things and memories with people that I
just will never remember it's actually
quite terrible yeah
because you know what I was thinking
you're gonna kill me oh God remember
like a couple years ago on the toast you
were quoting back something I had
allegedly said about getting on a plane
and stepping into a new land yeah so for
those who haven't been oh my God I
forgot about this fight so
I've laid down my arms I literally
forgot about can you retail okay so I I
think it was my belief that one time
Claudia and I were just like talking
about nonsense as we do and she said
something about the like magic of planes
and how you literally couldn't step onto
a plane and like you get off into a new
land and then on the toast like maybe
Weeks Later Jackie then regurgitated
what I had said and let me tell you I
did not say that like I'm like that's
just not something I said and then
actually I was thinking about this maybe
like a week ago it actually does sound
like something I would say and do you
actually look within do you feel that
way like that's cool to get on a plane
because you step off in a new land okay
so maybe like the way you told it back
wasn't accurate because what I was
saying was more like I don't want to get
into it but like
I think I said it let's just leave it at
that how come no one ever surfaced it
like if you did say it couldn't someone
just find it it was a personal
conversation I think when we were on a
plane that's a weird thing to say
personally like not on a show when we're
just trying to speak like be dumb we're
just trying to think of things to say
yeah I don't know why I said it like
maybe it was like a long day it's been a
year now like taking my position but I'm
now taking yours like I don't think you
would say that oh offline okay
it's something you would say on the air
maybe and it was a thought I had like I
definitely probably wouldn't have said
it to you because like I knew you would
have made fun of me no never yeah okay
well if anyone can go find that clip of
us like of me telling the story yeah
it's like old Studio yeah that's an old
one yeah I I forgot I let it go some
things I can't let go because she's
moving on letting go holding on to
tomorrow I've always got the memories
are you ready for our next story yeah
Bravo plans to revive Roni Legacy as a
girls trip Style Show with
Ramona and Luanne so Bravo's trying to
revive the real houses New York City
Legacy project as a short Real
Housewives ultimate girls trip style
show the network is hoping that Ramona
will be back as page six first reported
Bravo attempted to create a show with
the legacy cast as a spin-off show that
would be for a full season but that idea
fell apart during contract negotiations
now they're told that Executives have
retooled it as a special Style Show
documenting a short span of time in the
same way that ultimate girls trip covers
a vacation that takes place over just a
few days sources say it will be an
ultimate girls trip with the Roney
legacy cast and then I also saw some
rumors that it was going to be a trip to
scary Island and bringing the band back
together I saw that too
um I'm definitely getting uh
fatigued with this back and forth Roni
Legacy like I don't really care anymore
although I do think conceptually this is
probably a better idea than like a whole
different like new spin-off show yeah
because they're ultimate girls trips
for like a Die Hard Housewives fans are
popular so it's good I'm too far removed
to uh be a fan of this idea or any idea
at this point like one I don't watch the
ugts in general
um the idea of these women like going
for a one last hurray on a trip like
it's not even like they're in New York
and they're doing their lives and they
have to like you know vacation mode is
different than real life mode so it's
not it will just be absolute bananas
yeah and I'm not interested in bananas
no but what I do like about this article
is that some respect is being put on
Ramona's name because you know what say
whatever the [__] you want about Ramona
Singer like you cannot deny her
entertainment value especially with
these women she is I'm sorry like she is
that [__] and I think it pains a lot of
people to say that but like she is so
you know what I hope she's on it
honestly did you recap Vanderpump Rules
on no
no I don't even remember what happened
but I was just thinking about Watch What
Happens live with Tom Schwartz yeah I
did I did it was something to see it was
definitely a lot a lot so over him I've
been over him for so long I but I'm also
over him from the show like his behavior
on the show yeah and not even because of
Tom Sandoval like I I honestly has
nothing to do with Tom Sandoval no it
has a little bit to do with Tom Sandoval
because honestly the the way he like
alienates so many people like including
Katie right now
um but refuses to alienate Tom Sandoval
when like Tom Sandoval right now is
making Tom schwartzler like Tom Schwartz
has so much to answer for so many people
are mad at Tom schwarts like there's so
much happening to Tom Schwartz as a
result of Sandoval's actions and like he
still is not even remotely mad he was
telling everyone give Sandoval a hug if
you see him he's feeling down like but
he's so quick to throw like Katie under
the bus yeah it's just it's frustrating
yeah no but I I feel good about the fact
that I've been done with him since
before
skin yeah you know yeah like yeah
whatever
um and the only thing that happened on
Banner from Rules was
um Raquel and Tom made out
like who cares it's just at this point
it's so irrelevant yeah and
we'll talk about it later
I just I can't go a circle the train
anymore and now it's like we're in a
lull until those final episodes are in
The Reunion air it's like yeah we have
some time off yeah especially if we're
gonna keep going on about Tom and Raquel
Schwartz because it's irrelevant yeah
yeah like I'm taking the time off
dumbass to watch some other shows I'm
taking the time off like George and
Tammy right I love his mom
our fifth and final story which Claudia
requested oh yeah Claudia's request I'm
gonna read it even though I don't
understand the headline or anything
about it well let me just tell you a
little preface uh last night me and Ben
went to the movies so underrated can't
recommend going to the movies enough
even though the popcorn was like kind of
gross
um we saw air which is the story of
Michael Jordan making a deal with Nike
to do Air Jordan he had just uh I think
he was a freshman in college he was
assigned to the NBA there was a lot of
hype around other players he was the
third draft pick but he wasn't like you
know the biggest and pretty big yeah but
like with the three major companies at
the time which was Converse Adidas was
in first place Converse and then Nike
was a kind of losery they had like a
very small share of the basketball
Market
um they were never gonna get a top three
player like ever but you said he was
number three yeah they were never gonna
get a top three player and so how they
got the deal structured yada yada so
Viola Davis plays his mother she was
amazing
Ben Affleck plays Phil Knight the
founder of Nike and there is no Michael
Jordan
character he exists you see the back of
his head his mother really speaks for
him which I do think is how it was when
he was younger his mom ran the ship but
he doesn't say one word
it was so bizarre and so now the reason
I say the story is Ben Affleck is
explaining that artistic Choice Okay so
Ben Affleck explains why Michael Jordan
isn't shown in air by the way that movie
sounds really good and why haven't I
heard one thing about it I know Ben had
told me about it which is crazy because
Ben knows nothing
um you guys should totally see it it was
excellent yeah Zach was saying that oh
my God they saw air yeah I was like yeah
they saw air it was really good it's
also a weird name for a movie I can't
explain it I don't I didn't like the
name even though it's like a word yes
what the shoe was called it's not a
title Air Jordan would have been a
better it's not a title of a movie I
agree
air it was
Michael Jordan plays a pivotal role in
the movie air and is even present in a
few climactic boardroom pitch scenes yet
his face is not shown in the film aside
from shots of magazine covers and
Snippets of archival footage of the real
life player right we get the real
Michael Jordan in like old school yeah I
like when they do that
it's a bold Choice uh for the Amazon
Studios film because it's all about the
Nike Executives wooing explain this this
is what Ben Affleck said quote how do
you tell sorry this is what someone
asked him how do you tell a story about
Michael Jordan and never see him when
you are that person when you become so
much more than a hero or an athlete or
even an icon you start to become an idea
to people you touch them and just start
to represent hope and excellence and
greatness you are one of a kind
there is no way I was ever going to ask
an audience to believe that anybody
other than Michael Jordan was Michael
Jordan which was also out of my own
naked self-interest frankly because I
knew it would destroy the movie you will
see him in archival Clips in the movie
but you will see Michael Jordan as he
truly is
in his authentic masterful genius which
exists for all of us to see it was a
deliberate choice I thought he was too
Majestic to have anyone impersonate him
and as I told him you're too old to play
the part
um it was a terrible Choice disagree you
disagree with what I'm saying with Ben
Affleck yeah it was such a bad choice
and I really I I I don't feel like it
was deliberate I feel like maybe I don't
know it was such a bad it was my only
real problem with the movie
um especially because I understand what
he's saying like now Michael Jordan is
this Larger than Life real legend but at
the time he was like just a kid and he
was like doing what his mom said like I
really feel like it wouldn't have made
and didn't have to make him a huge part
of it because at the end of the day it
was all his mother she made the deal and
it was her idea that okay you're gonna
pay Michael this big amount but like
you're selling shoes with his name on it
we get a percentage of every sale and
that had never happened before royalty
deal it had never happened and it
chained now moving after that every
player who has a line gets a percentage
and it's like yeah this should this
money is being made off the likeness of
a player and the player in their family
should get that money in addition to
Nike yeah so it revolutionized like and
it was all her so I I get maybe him not
being the biggest character but like uh
okay like yeah and they talked about him
so much and then finally when they got a
meeting I'm like all right well we
haven't seen him up until this point but
we got a meeting
literally like his parents get out of
the limo and oh my God the actor who
played his dad I thought was Michael
Jordan like it was a perfect casting
they could have found someone like no
they could have and it's crazy that
we're having this conversation after
watching all these biopics it's like
right you can get Elvis you could do
Johnny Cash like all these people are
really Larger than Life and in the
stratosphere and we play them all the
time yep and sometimes it's and
sometimes it's not obviously like you
know Joaquin Phoenix is no Johnny Cash
of course but he did his best but we get
to see story of Johnny Cash sure yeah it
was so and they could have had Michael's
son play him it was so dumb and Martha
could have been there literally it was
so dumb that's dumb yeah I really liked
the movie I Didn't Know Much going into
it so I was surprised that like the
whole movie from start to finish is the
making of the deal we never get to see
like the deal come to life and then what
happens after he torture us I know and I
was just it and they gave statistics at
the end which are so unbelievable you
know to this day Michael Jordan makes
passive income every year and he only
didn't tell you what percentage he has a
small percentage of Air Jordan he
doesn't leave his house he makes 400
million dollars a year it is the
craziest thing and so I just wanted to
see a little bit more like literally
they signed the deal and the movie ends
I'm like that's on they always do that
they only focus on like the tumultuous
times and yeah when those are like a
small fraction of all the good times
even when I was watching George and
Tommy me like all the years the albums
that they did the success they have was
literally they should Montage a montage
of a bunch of albums like being dropped
down give us the good like give us the
joy no only the heartache and the
torture oh my God it was like so painful
um but it was excellent and the Jason
Bateman played like a pivotal guy at
Nike Matt Damon played the guy at Nike
and um Ben Affleck played shoe dog Phil
Knight and if I was film night like I
would have a problem with the movie
because yeah Phil Knight is like known
he was like he traveled to
Asia and like found all these like
Buddhist principles and brought back and
started Nike and like he's so he's
definitely like a little you know
out there
um but they made him out to be like a
freak a [__] and it's like you don't
build Nike by being a [__] like come on
like yeah he's weird and he does wear
shoes around the office but he has a
smart guy apparently his book is good
shoe dog yes it's apparently like the
go-to business book it's like the best
one Ben started and never finished
that's so bad that's so bad I keep
saying finish it I'm like maybe the
movie will want will encourage you to oh
we don't have another story because that
was five but we did have our Sixth Man
story of the day which was about Ben's
shoe on Friday's episode
Ben's shoe I don't know what you were
talking about for a second then she was
on Friday's episode so I do want to kind
of address the elephant in the room
which was on Friday I told you guys how
excited I was about trying something new
with our cameras I bought a second
camera for our studio I tried something
it definitely needs work you know the
angles aren't right I'm actually angry
I'm gonna head to the studio soon and
and work on it
um but I got dragged I got dragged to
fail with people being like this sucks
and my [__] husband's shoe was in the
frame the whole time I'm sorry for what
happened on Friday on YouTube I I am
even though I still think it looked
really good like you could still see
both of our faces so clear and up close
like isn't that what we want to see
facial reactions yeah no you were
focused on the face which I do think is
the primary yep but you weren't focused
on the wallpaper the Spritz and the show
and the table and then the [__] one and
it was a Friday with my Golden Shoe yeah
yeah but you did also ask people what do
you think of our new setup so they've
got a hundred thousand comments saying
Ben shoe okay here okay so I'm gonna
then shoe dog so tomorrow like we'll be
in studio with two cameras and let me
just say I don't want to know what you
think okay great great but I don't want
feedback but I watched the episode and I
saw the comments and I was like I wonder
if she asked people for their female
everyone's giving feedback I did twice
actually right and it was fun like at
least we'll always have Ben's shoe yeah
he's a shoe dog
he is the shoe dog so I actually really
recommend Nike shoe I really recommend
the movie by the way
um
I'm not gonna watch it no it was really
good but you just made it sound really
bad and if you um I don't know a lot
about Michael Jordan like I know he's
the goat and I know he like weirdly also
played in the MLB for a while because
he's just like such a great athlete he
could do anything
um it was really impressive and it made
me like I had a thirst for more
knowledge about Michael Jordan
and it was very good it was very good
okay that's good it was also just very
strangely
um
a guy who had a very small role played
by Marlon Wayans who was friends with
Matt Damon who was trying to get this
deal done and he was like getting advice
because he used to coach Michael Jordan
back in college
um
who was telling the story about
something that happened to him when he
went to like a Civil Rights march like
years ago how some guy handed him a
piece of paper and ended up in his
pocket it was a half of this guy's
speech
um and he looked at it after and it was
I Have a Dream speech it was like the
Martin Luther King accidentally like put
it in his pocket and I'm like that is
definitely not real and then at the end
when they have pictures of everyone side
by side with the real the actor and then
the real person
um it is a true story and that guy was
offered three million dollars for it and
he said no wow it was just like it was
also just like a like a very crazy
random um anecdote which really didn't
have anything to do with the story but
I'm like there's literally no way but it
was real that's crazy it was it was
crazy
so very good that's a good thing to do
um to go see if you like date night I I
recommend and or you could watch George
and Tammy which is on Showtime it's
about George Jones and Tammy Wynette you
know the king and queen of country music
it's crazy how I really didn't know who
they were at all Jessica Chas team plays
Tammy Wynette and Michael Shannon who
you would know his face plays George
Jones and he to me is the star of the
show like he really did amazing and I
don't like how they were singing like it
was the actor like I want to hear Tammy
Wynette sing
um also if you're looking for something
to watch you could watch succession oh
yeah we'll get into the recap but I want
to recap George and Tammy oh okay like I
just wanted to assist the TV recap yeah
yeah yeah okay it could be the TV recap
so is it today is it the TV recap that's
brought to you by manscaped yeah ladies
you want to look like George Jones our
friends our friends at manscaped are
here to with a deal you can pass over
this Easter season they've got the tools
to give the man in your life the
beautifully decorated eggs of his dreams
just because it's Easter doesn't mean
it's okay for him to hide his manhood
behind all that grass make sure his
downstairs lawn is mowed and get him
feeling sweet as candy by going to
manscape.com and you can get 20 off plus
free shipping with code toast it's time
to put all your eggs in the perfect
basket with the performance package 4.0
from manscaped inside you'll find their
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed whacker
2.0 ear hair ear and nose hair trimmer
the crop preserver ball deodorant the
crop reviver toner the performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold all of
his goodies so the lawnmower 4.0 is an
elite electric trimmer it has a
proprietary and skin safe technology the
lawnmower 4.0 is also waterproofed and
equipped with an LED light so you can
keep eyes on those eggs even in the dark
the package also comes with their crop
preserver ball deodorant and crop
reviver ball toner so it's a ball
deodorant that will change his life and
yours April is Easter but it's also
testicular cancer awareness month and
manscapes has partnered with the
testicular cancer society to bring
awareness to testicular cancer Men's
Health and early cancer detection they
are committed at manscape to raising
awareness for the most common form of
cancer in men aged 15 to 35 and they're
giving support for Fighters survivors
and families impacted by testicular
cancer as a part of their we save balls
initiative save 20 off and free shipping
with the code toast at manscaped.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with the
code toast at manscaped.com hop into the
best deal of the year with manscaped
today's episode is also brought to you
by Squarespace we are so excited to be
working with Squarespace from websites
and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business so
whatever you're wanting to create a
website for whether you have a blog or
you work in e-commerce you want to start
like an e-commerce side hustle check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use the
offer code toast and you'll save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain so again that's squarespace.com
toast Squarespace is the place to sell
anything they have the tools that you
need to get your business off the ground
including e-commerce templates inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
squarespace's merchandising features to
make your products look their best
online they also have video blocks you
can connect your social media accounts
you get traffic overview so you can see
how your visits unique visitors page
views are trending over time you can
gain insight into the top traffic
sources products device types browsers
and operating systems and the best part
is the content ownership so you own all
of the content you put on the
Squarespace platform they offer a
one-click data portability so check out
Squarespace at squarespace.com toast for
that free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain again that's Squarespace
s-q-u-a-r-e
s-p-a-c-e.com slash chose for that free
trial and offer code toast to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain thank you Claudia you're
welcome Jackie you support small
business owners big time in a big way
yeah okay George and Tammy before we get
into succession I'll be brief about it
because it was really good I feel like
it's a show that you know no one's
really talking about it didn't get that
much Buzz or a critical claim but it was
totally up there and high value great
people story again weird that I didn't
really like I don't know George Jones
you know some of the songs and Tammy
Wynette and so it was cool to like see
them in action Jessica Chastain is a
fabulous Queen but like she's Jessica
Chastain it's so hard to
to think of her as someone else yeah and
I just feel like I didn't get to I don't
understand Tammy why not as a person at
all I mean who's to know people but I
just felt like the character was almost
inconsistent a little bit uh but it was
really enjoyable I think it's six
episodes premium quality premium content
country music lots of other country folk
you should watch a dirty Lou yeah and
then you'll want to recap it yeah no
you're not like selling it no it was
good it's a crazy story like I I didn't
even know that they were you know King
and that they were like in love and
recording music together and it was just
like really cute they would literally
like get together and write a song about
getting together they got married they
wrote a song about that they get into a
fight like the whole world was a part of
their relationship via their songs
um I didn't know that they were like
such a I guess like Garth and Trisha but
we don't even know about Garth and like
we don't know anything about them do
they even live together like you know
like guards and Trisha are like first
lady and president of country music but
like not really yeah like her tour bus
literally said first lady because she
was the first lady of country music oh
who's Tammy oh they were talking about
Trisha Yearwood no like Trisha Yearwood
doesn't really even like perform or
write new music that much anymore she
was like a cooking show she's very much
like um
she's like a celebrity yeah
so it was interesting to like they had
this huge Larger than Life it's like I
can't imagine living through like being
a fan of theirs there there was so much
content they were giving I also feel
like Faith Hill and Tim McGraw were are
probably more
yeah of a comparison right yeah
yeah I don't know because Garth is just
so big but that's what the George Jones
like he was the king he was bigger than
her bigger than Tammy yeah well when
they met yes and then like he was had a
drinking problem he was on the decline
she was on the up oh did she get as big
as him yeah
I think it's faith in Tim you think it's
fake I think I feel like they're really
not equal
no I agree with that but I think faith
and Tim are not as big as George and
Tammy were right right but it was really
big yeah I feel like there's one other
country music couple that kept coming to
my it would have been like Blake and
Miranda I know if they had stuck it out
they really would have been like the
next Tammy and George were only married
for six years
oh and like the the whole show is like
you know they were always like each
other's one but then when you look at
their whole life story
I didn't think that they were like they
tried to make the case but like she was
married five times she was so in love
with George but they were married for
six years and then she married someone
else and was married to him for 20 years
oh so he wasn't the one
but but the 20-year relationship was
extremely nefarious
I hate to see it yeah no it the way like
I don't want to spoil anything but it
was nice not knowing their story yeah I
don't know anything because I was
shocked maybe added to a list of things
like I say no and then I will you know
it's only six episodes I just went I was
shocked by the way things went oh wow it
wasn't just like Boy Meets Girl right
June and Johnny Cash right oh June and
Johnny Cash are another yes Junior
there's so much of that in country music
it's nice it's like a very family like
genre and I'm sure if we thought long
and hard about like just music
relationships like Beyonce and Jay-Z
yeah they're the first lady and
president or she's more of the president
and first man uh of the music industry
yeah and specifically their genre yeah
um okay let's do this guys succession
I've just like never really felt more
difficult I did yeah spoilers I have
never really felt more disconnected from
my generation than I did last night
going on Twitter and reading people's
thoughts on succession about the Emmys
how they'll be walking into the Emmys
for this episode literally people were
like I was in tears this is the most
profound acting this is the best show on
television I was really shocked because
I was really frustrated watching last
week's episode where nothing happened or
like it was like maybe one thing is
going to happen and the whole episode
we're on the edge of our seats is
something gonna happen we didn't even
find out if something that thing was
gonna happen this week
um and but something did happen and the
whole time I was just kind of like he's
not
yeah he's not I'm like this is a prank
he's testing to see who loves him the
most I didn't think it was a prank at a
certain point at the beginning I did but
then I didn't it was weird that they
never showed his body so I was like it
was misleading
and then I was like well they'll revive
him and this was just like maybe a way
to get the family back together but then
the fact that they actually did it was
like the only interesting yeah thing so
it's like they sat around the writer's
table they were like we're gonna kill
Logan and we're gonna make you spend the
whole episode wondering if he's dead
yeah and that's gonna win us an Emmy
yeah I'm just I'm not understanding why
everyone is so guffawed over this
episode like yeah no it was it was good
to see all the kids like finally be
human yeah but that's not an Emmy may
but like you were estranged and those
people on the plane like even though
they were like they they care about the
business and their work like they worked
for Logan and they supported him over
the years and you made his last year a
misery yeah no I
I just I was not feeling anyone or
anything like Conor everyone's pissing
me off and I don't know why they didn't
show us his body or face it was very
it's getting like Bart bass like he's
coming back yes I literally and like the
only one who went up to see his body is
Roman and like Roman knows that he's
still alive and there's a whole that's
like so not this shot I know I know it's
not a soap it's based in realism which I
appreciate it if only it was a soap
opera and dramatic things happened yeah
instead we're now like so the only thing
that's happened this season is that
Logan has died because the first episode
with the p uh Pierce acquisition null
and void everything that happened in
that episode is irrelevant now second
episode Gojo will they won't they back
out it's still relevant now because you
know what now if they want to back out
of the deal the kids have to go and ask
that guy for more money when literally
that guy called Kendall and said you
will not get another Penny out of me and
Kendall's been knowing that and again
Daniel sent his dad to Switzerland yeah
knowing it was a moot point they also
can't buy Pierce without the sale so
they're not going I mean it's so dumb so
now the show is about did you watching
that like coming up now the show is
about who is the new CEO oh and that was
the question in episode one when Logan
had his health scare so in Four Seasons
and in one whole year you never figured
out who's gonna succeed Logan and no one
is up for the test they need to bring in
outside help there's really not one
character I unequivocally like no except
Colin
Connor Colin the drive the driver and he
got one scene and it was like actually
really sad that's like his friend and
like I just I felt sad for him besides
that like I I know this is gonna be a
hot take because everybody loves him I
[__] hate cousin Greg like he's so
inept I just I hate everyone and I know
I I the show is like satire I get it I
don't like it but it's not like I know
people say that but it's not because
like satire is really funny and I know
that but like no one's laughing when
you're watching maybe there's one good
joke every episode but you know who's
making the joke Logan yeah and now our
comic relief and on any sense of like
smartness is gone everyone else is so
[__] dumb yeah and even the people
who work for Logan at least they have
like you know business savvy
but they're all just like scared of
what's gonna happen that scene with
Carrie was odd
well she was weird when she was like
smiling but they were just happy to be
rid of her yeah no and they were being
funny
um like about her but it was just weird
like why was she smiling I have no idea
but like she's irrelevant now and I do
acknowledge that there's a lot that goes
on in the show like in terms of business
and then just in terms of like writing
that definitely goes over my head I like
don't understand this show no two
actually subtitles of course then you'll
understand and here's what here's what
you need to understand
and everyone speaks like that yeah well
is it it uh in play uh cause like
everyone's always nervous all the time
no one is cogent except for Logan I just
I I've come to dread the show no and now
without my only character who I I liked
I I I'll finish the season but I'm not
watching it week to week is that okay
like oh wow I just I the last night was
painful yeah and I was really tired and
I wanted to go to sleep it was a painful
episode and Ben who watches
with me but doesn't know much I'd like
explain but he doesn't know like the
backstory he's like the show's terrible
I'm like no I know oh uh uh the plane um
he was in the bathroom and when yeah
when Tom was like trying to convey at
first what was going on it was so how do
these people reach these levels of
success when they can't communicate yeah
it's a good question so but let's just
give predictions who do you think takes
over
Matson oh that would be like unexciting
but yeah like no one it's not gonna be
one of the kids because they're each
dumber than the next
um and the only one who's smart is Roman
and Shivan Kendall will never let him
yeah succeed them yeah uh
and then none of the worker bees Jerry
Carolina Hugo Yeah Carl whatever Hugo it
has to be an outside force Tom thinks
he's up for it I know
so does Greg in some weird capacity who
do you think I don't know
there's no like obvious choice no
they're all inept and they're all like
just dumb and annoying I like hate the
show hate yeah I don't know if I hate it
because like when you start to hate
something like you you always like have
a way of making me then hate that thing
but like I think I hate it because like
it's bad no last thing was I just don't
know if I'm so influenced by my older
cool sister who's like always smart you
know so sweet but no you would have
hated last name regardless it's horrible
torturous I'm happy Conor got married
yeah me too and you know what it's nice
it is is it great no is it good yes it's
good it's good can't expect to be like
so happy in every part of your life you
know knowing like she's growing to love
him yeah and she's really supportive of
him yeah and she just feels and they
have like an understanding that like yes
he has money and like she's craving that
sort of stability But You Learn to Love
the One You're With yeah it's nice it is
it's not like anyone else has a
relationship so true
um okay well that's our show that was a
succession recap that was your TV recap
sandwich your TV recap sandwich it was
stuffed with lots of meaty TV Recaps
it's so meaty make sure to keep an eye
on the toast Instagram today because I
will be posting the schedule we have
four guest co-hosts today works really
hard on the schedule so I'm gonna let
her know how I was bothering like
everyone I knew to get like good people
so just keep that in mind is there a day
in particular excited for don't say who
but just okay no they're all like
equally good honestly
yeah I'm excited to watch so Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday I'm in studio
video and audio with all of my guests so
make sure to subscribed on YouTube
following us on Instagram thank you so
much for listening to the testimony
everybody on YouTube subscribing this
video thumbs up rolls available
talented we are hope you guys have a
great day happy Monday and we'll see you
tomorrow love ya bye